i swear i have absolutely no idea what
women are thinking i don't get it okay
i i i admit i i'm not getting the
signals i am not
getting it women they're they're so
subtle they're little
everything they do is subtle men
are not subtle we are obvious women know
what men want men know what men want
what do we want
we want women that's it
[Applause]
it's the only thing we know for sure it
really is we want women how do we get
them oh we don't know
about that we don't know the next step
after that we have no idea this is why
you see men honking car horns yelling
from construction sites
these are the best ideas we've had so
far
the car horn honk is that the beauty
have you seen men doing this
what is this the man is in the car the
woman walks by the front of the car
he honks
this man is out of ideas
[Music]
i don't think she likes me
[Laughter]
the amazing thing is that we still get
women don't we men i mean men are with
women you see men with women
how are men getting women many people
wonder let me tell you a little bit
about our organization
whatever women are we have a man working
on the situation right now
now he may not be our best man
okay we have a lot of areas to cover but
someone from our staff
is on the sink that's why i think men
get frustrated when we see women reading
articles
like where to meet men we're here we are
everywhere
we're honking our horns to serve you
better
[Applause]
and the only reason you get that we
don't go get the [ __ ] out of here
is cause you you women are the worst
terrorists
there are worse than al qaeda because
this is what y'all do
you hold the [ __ ] hostage
and threaten to kill it if we don't
listen to your horrendous nonsense
and you make it read a letter to puss if
you're reading the letter please
please listen to her story but she's
going to kill me
and you'll never see me again
look at him look at it look this posture
this ain't good when girls
are the girls do that he hates women he
hates what
somebody got to tell you
let me ask you a question here's a
question here's a serious question
okay ladies if you didn't have a vagina
like say it was a terrible train
accident right and the doctor
was like we have to remove your [ __ ]
right away
or you're gonna die
how would you keep your man passed
you get a two-month guilty i can't leave
the [ __ ] right away because you just
lost a [ __ ] in the train action
[Applause]
can't just walk right out on him
how would you keep your man past that
if you didn't have a regina
wow nothing you can talk you can talk
suck his dick okay mouth
[ __ ] okay great do you see what i'm
saying
now i've been getting [ __ ] being the
whole show right but i give women the
opportunity to say i'm gonna
make myself worth more but you just
classified yourself as a series of holes
but but you know i'm
i'm supposed to treat you special but
you're just a bunch of hoes for yourself
no one said learn how to play xbox learn
how to play pool
tell better stories get another [ __ ]
that got a [ __ ] to come on in
well look whatever
we like the way you look sometimes i
feel like women don't realize that we
like the way you look
you do some weird-ass [ __ ] you know
there's these girls that will take
eyelashes and put them
on top of their already existing
eyelashes
is that not [ __ ] a little bit no
guys
ever said you know i wasn't a [ __ ] but
huh unless it's not
voluminous
[Applause]
you should have seen the the air coming
off
every time she blinked just she blew out
the birthday candles with her [ __ ]
blanket
happy birthday this hair nonsense we
don't [ __ ] care
i had an ex-girlfriend say to me she's
like you know i shaved my vagina
for you i was offended
i was like hold on you think [ __ ] hair
is gonna stop
me
do you even know what i'm capable of
the only difference when you go down on
a girl she's got [ __ ] hair is
afterwards
that's the only one
you think it's gonna stop a man from
being [ __ ]
[ __ ] i eat popcorn
[Applause]
you can't eat popcorn though
but never once have i been eating
popcorn i'm out i'm leaving the movie
i'm leaving the movie i'm out of here
just be consistent that's the only thing
we care about
i don't get these girls that will like
shave their legs shave their
armpits shave their vagina do their
eyebrows leave their mustache
i just want to be silky and so rough
i had a roommate once full mustache
thick mustache this was
she would bleach it
i'm not a teller like it's not the color
ah
it's the mustache that's the issue
no guy goes you know what she look good
with a blonde mustache that's
like a hulk hogan face that's what i'm
into
that's what i want when a girl's going
down on me is you want that dick suck
brother
you like that i can't hear you
i just envy women a lot of ways
especially getting older when i get
older you talk to each other about any
change that happens on your body
i find that amazing anything weird
happens oh my god did that happen to you
what happened to me
drink white wine and work it out
and don't do that anything weird happens
on our body we don't tell anybody oh god
i hope that tumor is normal and we're
dead
six months later dead i don't want to
burn my doctor with this information
there's another reason why i think that
it's an unfair process
that fema women go through sometimes and
their scheme gets damaged and there's a
biological sort of reason for it too
that i didn't even know about
and it happened one night i was uh i was
high i apologize
but sometimes when i watch television i
was watching a show on the discovery
channel called the
the human animal with desmond morris the
show about anthropology yeah
now i uh watched this show and it
started talking about the differences
between the two genders now i always
thought basically were the same except
audit outdoor plumbing you had indoor
plumbing yeah
why not this show told me that women's
brains actually developed completely
different from men
apparently in the womb three months in
the female brain is exposed to low doses
of estrogen and progesterone which
causes the frontal cortex to start
growing at a roughly one-third faster
rate than the male brain
causing more synapses and axioms to form
to clusters which retain more
descriptive language in their vocabulary
so that by age 21 they have roughly 5
500 more words than the average guy
holy crap
[Applause]
[Music]
that that is an amazing statistic to
land on somebody who's high because
right away i had a breakthrough you know
one of those moments where oh
and i felt this weight lift off my
shoulders
where i realized i don't have to feel
bad anymore about not knowing what the
hell you're talking about
you have your own language at your
disposal and i'm like that's incredible
what a gift
what a powerful tool you have i'm like
okay cool well we must have gotten
something as men and we did we were
given a special skill so
called this spatial conception and
three-dimensional rotation i thought
what can i do with that fight crime
here's what we can do we can go through
a box of bolts right go ahead look at
that bolt and go through a box of nuts
and hey look at that nut
i bet those two fit together
that's it
[Applause]
but there's one activity that i find
hilarious and funny and unfortunate
that you uh because of spatial
conception have a problem with and
it's getting dressed what are you
talking about because of spatial
conception i've never met a girl that
can tell what fits until they actually
attempt to try it on
now the worst situation for this is when
you're getting ready for a special event
though like a christmas party or a staff
party and you want to look your best
and we'll be getting dressed in the room
with you oh my god i've watched women
get ready and they're getting
to go through that closet trying to find
that perfect dress and they're like oh
my god i forgot about this one
and they'll show it to you and they're
so excited i'm going to wear this
tonight
now what sucks about that moment when
we're in the room with you
is i'll be 15 feet away and i can
clearly see
[Applause]
that ain't gonna fit
[Applause]
but i don't have enough words to tell
[Applause]
you
[Applause]
i'm left in the position of having to
lie go yeah try that on that'll look
great
because it's funny to watch you try and
adjust it doesn't fit i know that sounds
awful but it's funny because you start
off happier yeah
because it always fits over your arms
[Music]
but then the happy goes away when the
entire dress is in one ball above your
breasts
and this confusion says what's going on
what is this i don't what is this and
then you try to bring us into babies it
caught on something back there can you
see
and that's a trick question right there
because you can't be honest yeah
big role you don't feel that
everything in my brain says that dress
shouldn't fit but once in a while you'll
make it fit have you ever watched a girl
make a dress fit into me you'll do
things that i've never had to do getting
dressed like you'll bend your knees
that's not weird peter a lot of people
blend their knees yeah but the entire
dress is above your breasts
then you'll start breathing
are you going pearl diving
and you do this move i love this move
and i know you've seen this move where
you'll cup
the bottom of the breast yeah right over
there
and you hold the dress and it all comes
together in this cirque du soleil move
where you jump breathe out push the tid
in
the tip disappears through stargate i
don't know where the tip goes
pull the dress down the tent reappears
where did you learn that i have giant
balls i don't have a move like that
[Applause]
you can see it never ever had this
happen this is how confusing it is this
this is the practical application what
i'm talking about like a guy be out just
having a lot of guys you'll be out of
club
ball right you're just kicking with your
boys and and a girl walks by
and man she looks good she looks good
not good in that
classical way i mean you know i'm
talking good like
she got half her ass hanging out her
skirt
her titties are all mashed together
popping out the top of her turtleneck
and [ __ ]
[Applause]
and you with your buddies right you're
with your buddies you got a couple
drinks in here and your cigarettes you
might try to talk to this might not come
out right
i don't know what you say damn look at
them titties
[Applause]
the girl can spanish wait a minute wait
a minute
just because i'm dressed this way
does not
make me a [ __ ]
which is true gentlemen that is true
just because they dress a certain way
doesn't mean they are a certain way
don't ever forget it but ladies you must
understand that that is [ __ ]
confusing that would be like me
dave chappelle the comedian walking
around the streets and the cop in the
fall
somebody might run up on me oh thank god
officer
help us come on they're over here help
us
just because i'm dressed this way
does not make me a police officer
you understand what i'm saying it's like
all right lady
fine fine you are not a [ __ ]
but you are wearing a horse uniform i'll
tell you that
[Music]
[Music]
you